il n'y a pas de véritable explication
c'est un crime gratuit ça crime pour
rien il y avait pas de mobile c'est
parce qu'elle est passée là
il y a pas d'autres explications
allez lancer du verdict il reste
impassible
il réalise pas je crois qu'il réalise
pas ce qu'il y arrive il comprend pas
tout quoi là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous sommes le 10 mai 2001 à Clairac
petit village du Lot-et-Garonne
[Musique]
il est 11h du matin dans cette maison
une femme de ménage passe l'aspirateur
soudain elle découvre un bout de papier
chiffonné
un mot qui est écrit d'une main assez
mal habile et qui indique que c'est moi
qui ai tué à Clairac le 31 juillet 1991
[Musique]
sans le savoir cette femme de ménage a
entre les mains la solution d'un crime
vieux de 10 ans le meurtre d'une jeune
fille de 18 ans Caroline nolibet
le 31 juillet 1991 au lieu-dit de
Longueville en bordure du village de
Clairac
la soirée est avancée lorsque Claude
nolibet un ouvrier de 52 ans est
soudainement réveillé par un bruit
étrange
c'est un peu avant 23h que Claude libey
qui est allé se coucher
en temps son chien qui râle parce que ce
chien est malade depuis plusieurs jours
et ça l'inquiète donc il va se lever
ouvrir les il ouvre les volets de sa
fenêtre il ne voit rien parce qu'il fait
nuit et du coup quand même très intrigué
parce que les râles se prolonge il
enfile son pantalon et il descend voir
se rend dans la véranda et allume la
lumière
et découvre cette scène assez atroce par
un père de famille
il aperçoit donc le corps de d'une
personne c'est une jeune femme c'est sa
fille Caroline nolybe 18 ans
la jeune fille est recroquevillée au
pied du portail inerte
[Musique]
donc il se précipite il la met sur le
dos
Caroline est couverte de sang elle est
gémissante mais respire encore
Claude il est paniqué complètement
paniqué donc ben oui il sait pas il
prend sa fille dans ses bras et il lui
demande de parler il lui demande de ce
qui s'est passé il tourne en rond et la
première idée il faut appeler de secours
le père de Caroline se rue à l'intérieur
de la maison pour appeler le médecin de
famille là il cafouille parce que il a
un espèce de cadenas sur le téléphone
précisément pour empêcher sa fille de
passer trop de trop d'appels il se
souvient pas d'où il a mis l'endroit où
il a mis la clé après quelques minutes
de veines tentatives Claude nolybe se
précipite à l'extérieur pour demander du
secours
il préfère aller chez son voisin voisin
immédiat de l'autre côté de la rue pour
alerter de ce qu'il vient de se produire
et demander à sa voisine d'appeler le
médecin ce qu'elle va faire Claude
nolibet retourne immédiatement au chevet
de Caroline accompagné de son voisin
mais il est trop tard
sa fille a cessé de respirer et donc
elle est morte
arrivée sur les lieux le médecin
constate le décès de Caroline
une mort à première vue très violente
il prévient immédiatement les gendarmes
légendes sont avisés par téléphone de la
découverte d'un corps
à Clairac donc au domicile de Monsieur
nolivier
ils arrivent sur la scène de crime
quelques minutes plus tard
à l'intérieur donc de la petite courette
j le corps de Caroline nolibet dans une
mare de sang les gendarmes découvrent le
corps de Caroline allongé sur le dos
elle a été retournée par son père aucun
vêtement né déchiré aucun il n'y a pas
de trace de bagarre il y a pas de traces
de lutte elle n'a pas été déshabillée un
examen sommaire du corps révèle que
Caroline a été frappé avec une arme
blanche
les éléments montrent que
Caroline Olibet a été poignardée à
plusieurs reprises
dans la région du cœur
l'arme du crime est introuvable à
proximité du corps les enquêteurs ne
relèvent aucun indice suspect pas la
moindre empreinte qui permettrait
d'identifier l'agresseur
[Musique]
après s'être occupé du corps de la
victime du vent maintenant pénétrer à
l'intérieur de la maison et là il
découvre sur la porte de la cuisine un
trou saute clé qui est situé sur la
serrure extérieure c'est un porte-clé
qui comporte un petit cœur en forme de
coussin sur lequel il y a imprimé je
t'aime et qui était le porte-clé de
Caroline pour les enquêteurs la jeune
fille était donc sur le point de rentrer
chez elle quant elle a été agressée puis
tu es quelques mètres plus loin au pied
du portail d'entrée
juste à côté de la porte de la cuisine
les gendarmes relèvent de nombreuses
traces de sang
il découvre sur le volet extérieur le
volet de la porte de la cuisine
une tâche de sang
à hauteur de la hauteur d'homme
[Musique]
que l'on ne peut voir que lorsque les
volets sont fermés
s'agit-il du sang de la victime ou du
meurtrier impossible de le savoir pour
le moment toujours est-il qu'à
l'intérieur de la maison il y a du sang
un peu partout
dans la salle de séjour sur le téléphone
et le carnet d'adresses mais ce n'est
pas tout il y a des traces de pas de
Claude nolibet qui était pieds nus et
qui est allé dans la maison pour essayer
de téléphoner et qui a donc laissé une
empreinte de pas sur le sol de sa maison
Claude nolibet et sous le choc il est
couvert de sang
il a les mains en sanglantées et il a la
joue ensanglanté parce qu'il s'est
penché sur le torse de Caroline pour
écouter ses battements de cœur dans la
panique le père de la victime a laissé
des traces de sang un peu partout dans
la maison à l'intérieur il n'y a pas la
moindre trace de lutte ce qui semble
confirmer que Caroline a bien été tué
dans la cour pour quelle raison et par
qui
[Musique]
Claude nolybe est immédiatement entendu
à la brigade de gendarmerie de Clairac
les gendarmes possèdent aux auditions
des témoins on va du plus près au plus
loin évidemment le plus près étant dans
cette enquête
monsieur no limites qui a découvert le
corps de sa de sa fille donc il va être
entendu tout d'abord sur son entre
guillemets son curriculum vitae de
savoir un petit peu comment il vit qu'il
est ce qu'il fabrique etc donc Claude
nolibet va répondre évidemment aux
questions des gendarmes il se trouve
qu'il vit seul depuis 18 mois avec sa
fille il est séparé de sa femme qui est
parti avec un autre homme elle a donc
choisi son père c'est quand même pas une
démarche
neutre et il était très fier de ce choix
c'était donc un Père très aimant avec
une fille très aimante vers ce qu'on
perd il ne ressort pas de difficultés à
ce stade de l'enquête en tout cas entre
eux
[Musique]
se poursuit
Claude nolybe est entendu sur son emploi
du temps
il va expliquer en détail
heure par heure ce qu'il a fait dans la
journée il a travaillé une partie d'une
grande partie de la journée il est
rentré chez lui à l'heure du déjeuner il
a d'ailleurs croisé sa fille Caroline
cette occasion lui ensuite est reparti
retourner travailler il a terminé sa
soirée par une partie de pêche puis il a
terminé je crois vers 21h il rentre à ce
moment là la maison est vide selon
Claude nolybe rien d'anormal Caroline
Dinet fréquemment chez sa mère ou chez
des amis sans leur informer il dîne donc
seul
il est parti se coucher à 21h55
il est très précis sur le 21h55 parce
qu'il a regardé son réveil
on lui demande simplement comment il a
découvert le
corps de sa de sa fille comment il a
prévenu les secours comment quels ont
été ses premiers gestes quel est ses
premiers réflexe
donc là il donne des explications
assez assez concise les gendarmes
interrogent clonolibet sur les clés de
Caroline ces clés retrouvées dans la
serrure de la porte d'entrée
et l'homme livre une version surprenante
[Musique]
lui dit aux enquêteurs que
Caroline avait laissé ses clés
c'est avec ces clés là celle de Caroline
qu'il a ouvert la porte il prétend il
affirme avoir mis lui-même le trousseau
de clés dans la serrure l'homme explique
même les avoir laissés en évidence à
l'extérieur pour que Caroline rentre
sans difficulté durant la nuit
Claude nolibet est entendu jusqu'à 4h30
du matin rien dans ses déclarations ne
permet d'orienter les enquêteurs sur la
piste du meurtrier
comme il est d'usage les enquêteurs
s'intéressent alors à la vie de la
victime
Caroline a quitté l'école à 16 ans elle
est ouvrière dans une entreprise de la
région elle n'a pas de petite amie et à
la réputation d'être une jeune fille
épanouie collègue amis sont unanime
Caroline était une fille sans histoire
Caroline Olibet au départ et décrite
comme une fille gentille caroline
nonolibet est une jeune fille qui vit
avec son temps une jeune fille qui a
parfois des robes courtes des jupes
courtes qui se maquillent et qui met des
beautés qui se fait les hommes comme
quelqu'un de normal avec des relations
pas de trucs qui puisse supposer qu'elle
a fait une que elle s'est mis dans un
pétrin et qu'elle l'a cherché quoi ou
qu'elle avait des mauvaises
fréquentations que ça peut-être plus mal
tourné rien de ça dans toute l'enquête
qui est faite on ne connaît pas
quelqu'un qui
a quelque chose contre
Caroline nolibet ce qui rend l'enquête
encore plus difficile parce que on se
dit mais pourquoi
pas d'ennemi connu les gendarmes vont
reconstituer l'emploi du temps de la
victime le jour du drame
on remonte ainsi facilement tous les
moments passés par Caroline la veille de
son agression et durant cette soirée on
sait que ce matin-là elle a commencé
très tôt 5 heures du matin elle
travaille depuis deux mois dans une dans
une entreprise de la région et elle
terminait à en fin de matinée je crois à
midi
les témoignages confirment que Caroline
a ensuite bien déjeuné avec son père
elle passe l'après-midi chez elle elle
travaille pas l'après-midi jusqu'à 19h
elle ne bougera pas de son domicile
bonjour elle se rend dîner chez son ami
Albert j'étais allé souvent elle quitte
ensuite la maison de son ami d'enfance
pour se rendre chez sa mère à quelques
mètres de là
[Musique]
équité des haricots avec sa mère et
l'ami de sa mère dans cette enquête de
sur son emploi du temps rien ne cloche à
22h30 la mère de la jeune fille lui
propose de la raccompagner Caroline
refuse
[Musique]
elle refuse de façon quelque part très
normale pour une jeune fille de cet âge
elle est pas loin elle veut pas déranger
ça lui fait du bien de marcher elle a
l'habitude et donc elle repart à pied
quelques minutes plus tard Caroline est
découverte agonisant dans la cour de sa
maison
que s'est-il passé pourquoi la jeune
fille a-t-elle été attaquée les
gendarmes n'en n'ont pas la moindre idée
seul certitude la mère de Caroline est
la dernière à l'avoir vu vivante
[Musique]
une fille sans histoire pas de zone
d'ombre dans son emploi du temps pour
les enquêteurs une seule possibilité
la jeune fille a forcément fait une
mauvaise rencontre quelqu'un a-t-il vu
ou entendu quelque chose
[Musique]
les gendarmes interrogent alors tous les
voisins de la famille nolibet qui
habitent dans une zone résidentielle les
gendarmes vont faire ce qu'on appelle
une enquête de voisinage histoire de de
retrouver d'éventuelles témoins qui
auraient pu voir Caroline passer ou qui
aurait pu voir Caroline importunée par
un individu ils vont voir tout le monde
je crois tout le monde sur le sur la
route entre entre la Maison de la Mer
qui est de l'autre côté du lot et celle
du père tout le monde a été vu ça c'est
certain rien est un Odin on rentre tout
tout le témoignages cette enquête de
voisinage s'est révélée infructueuse
jusqu'au jour où l'un de ses voisins
pousse la porte de la gendarmerie
[Musique]
un témoin se présente spontanément à la
gendarmerie pour signaler que dans le
créneau horaire qui nous intéresse c'est
à dire 22h30 23h alors qu'il promenait
son chien il a vu un individu tout seul
qui circulait à bord d'un véhicule Fiat
Panda immatriculé 33
la description est imprécie impossible
d'établir un portrait robot du
conducteur
les enquêteurs se rabattent donc sur le
modèle de la voiture et passe leur
fichiers au crible il cherche une Panda
immatriculée en Gironde à 120 km de là
on a essayé identifié toutes les Fiat
Panda
[Musique]
qui auraient pu passer là
ça n'a rien donné les gendarmes sont
dans l'impasse
restent une maison dans laquelle les
enquêteurs ne se sont pas encore rendus
l'une des maisons les plus proches du
lieu du crime est un CAT un centre
d'aide par le travail ou sont
pensionnaires des adultes handicapés
ce foyer pour handicaper mentaux est
situé à seulement 200 mètres de la scène
du meurtre
de ses pensionnaires aurait-il agressé
Caroline les enquêteurs se rendent sur
place
[Musique]
les gendarmes vont aller au CAT le
premier août au matin mais le CAT le
personnel est parti en vacances et le
CAT est fermé les enquêteurs trouvent
porte clauses
il contacte alors le directeur de
l'établissement par téléphone
celui-ci est formel tous les résidents
sont partis en vacances la veille du
drame en fin d'après-midi le centre
était donc vide à l'heure du crime
la piste est écartée
[Musique]
après plusieurs jours de recherche les
gendarmes se rendent à l'évidence à
Clairac personne n'a rien vu rien
entendu
les enquêteurs retournent sur les lieux
du drame peut-être ont-ils négligé une
piste
ils vont fouiller les abords dire la
cour et caniveaux les poubelles du coin
ils le font encender le puits
et puis il y a l'autre qui est pas très
loin et du coup ils ont fait revenir une
équipe de plongeurs de la gendarmerie
afin de retrouver cette arme du crime
les gendarmes sont un peu perdus parce
qu'on ne trouve pas d'armes on trouve
pas d'armes blanches et il est
vraisemblable que la mort a été donnée
par un coup de couteau mais ce couteau
n'est pas là les recherches dans le
jardin et aux alentours du domicile de
Claude nolybe ne donne rien les
enquêteurs décidèrent alors de fouiller
la maison de la victime de fond en
comble et ils ne vont pas tarder à faire
d'intéressantes découvertes
les gendarmes vont s'attarder longuement
dans la chambre de Claude nolybe dans
laquelle ils vont trouver trois couteaux
deux opinels un numéro 7 un numéro 8 et
également un couteau suisse
évidemment ces armes vont être
saisis et envoyer au laboratoire afin
d'expertise histoire de savoir si il y a
des traces de sang sur ces trois
couteaux
en plus de ces trois couteaux les
gendarmes saisissent tous les vêtements
que Claude nolibet portait le soir du
crime pourquoi l'homme cachait-il trois
couteaux dans sa chambre
étrange
a-t-il quelque chose à se reprocher les
enquêteurs ont tendance à le croire
d'autant qu'une semaine seulement après
le crime à Clairac les rumeurs vont bon
train
ma petite commune de Clairac les langues
se sont des liées
Claude nolibet homme quinquagénaire
multipliant les aventures sa fille
Caroline nolibet également fille VOLAJ
qui elle aussi sortait beaucoup on dit
que c'est une jeune fille facile alors
là
on n'avait pas relevé ça non de notre
première investigations mais il a fallu
en tenir compte un rien ne permet
d'étayer ses accusations de filles
volages par contre les gendarmes ne vont
pas tarder à découvrir la relation
fusionnelle de Caroline et son père
[Musique]
Caroline nolibet était devenu la
véritable maîtresse de maison entre
guillemets c'était elle qui avait
remplacé la maman à la maison Claude
nolybe se reposer entièrement sur sa
fille ce couple
si il perd n'est pas passé inaperçu
et certains témoins disent que ben ils
sont peut-être un petit peu plus que
flipper et là on commence à parler
peut-être d'une relation incestueuse
entre le père et la fille
d'une jalousie
aux yeux des gendarmes Claude nolibet
apparaît comme un personnage de plus en
plus trouble un homme qui cacherait bien
son jeu et qui n'aurait pas dit toute la
vérité
Caroline a-t-elle cherché à s'éloigner
de son père les enquêteurs vont trouver
la réponse dans la correspondance saisit
dans la chambre de la jeune fille
Caroline a reçu un courrier quelques
temps plus tôt d'une de ses amis qui lui
proposait du boulot dans la Veyron
et donc là pour les gendarmes ça devient
presque un mobile face à devient mobile
Claude olybet aurait mal vécu le départ
de sa fille ça c'est certain parce que
pour lui il perdait une deuxième fois
son épouse Claude nolibet aurait-il tué
sa propre fille pour qu'elle ne le
quitte pas l'idée commence à germer dans
la tête des enquêteurs et du procureur
de la République et l'autopsie de
Caroline va conforter cette intuition
selon le rapport du médecin légiste la
jeune fille n'a pas subi de violences
sexuelles
elle est morte d'une hémorragie
importante due à un coup de couteau
porté en plein cœur
mais surtout l'autopsie donne une
indication précieuse sur le déroulement
du crime
cette autopsie nous montre également
qu'elle n'a vraiment eu aucun geste de
défense c'est-à-dire une absence totale
de lésions de défense au niveau des
coudes au niveau des mains elle était
tout à fait capable de crier sauf si le
meurtrier l'empêchait de le faire elle a
laissé son agresseur l'approcher
suffisamment près ça colle parfaitement
bien avec l'hypothèse selon laquelle
elle connaissait par bien son agresseur
Caroline ne se serait donc pas méfiée de
celui qui l'a tué pour les gendarmes
Claude nolybe devient le principal
suspect et ils ne vont pas tarder à
découvrir que l'homme leur a menti sur
un détail
[Musique]
une semaine après le meurtre la mère de
Caroline est de nouveau entendue dans
les locaux de la gendarmerie et elle
livre un détail très troublant au sujet
des clés
[Musique]
la maman de Caroline qui a vu sa fille
environ un quart d'heure avant qu'elle
ne soit tuée la maman dit mais elle
avait ses clés avec elle et d'ailleurs
mon ami lui a fait une réflexion à
propos du Petit Coeur etc
l'audition de monsieur nolibet va à
l'encontre de cette de cette
constatation
depuis le début de l'enquête l'homme
soutient que Caroline a oublié ses clés
et que c'est lui qui les a mis sur la
porte le soir du drame
[Musique]
on ne comprend pas que pourquoi mais je
no Libye dit que se trouve ce était là
et donc les gendarmes sont persuadés que
Claude Olivet leur manque quand il dit
que c'est lui qui a utilisé les clés de
Caroline et
à partir de là j'ai presque envie de
vous dire que la mécénite pour les
gendarmes parce que si elle est en
possession de clés forcément Claude
nolibet ment
et ce n'est pas la seule incohérence du
témoignage du père de Caroline
un voisin qui promenait son chien le
soir du crime remet en cause les
déclarations de Claude nolibet
c'est ce témoin qui affirme avoir vu de
la lumière dans la chambre de Claude
nolibet à 22h30 or lui depuis le début
dit qu'il a éteint les feux à 21h55 donc
c'est un mensonge supplémentaire ça veut
dire ca 22h30 il était réveillé or on
sait que le crime a lieu à 23 heures
pourquoi tous ces mensonges en raison de
ces contradictions les gendarmes
décident d'interpeller le père de
Caroline
le 12 août 1991 les enquêteurs arrêtent
Claude nolibet quand il lui signifie sa
garde à vue l'homme n'oppose aucune
résistance
il abat-jourd’hui mais il comme pas son
innocence c'est menottés et étroitement
surveillés qui quitte sa maison
il est conduit à la gendarmerie
les enquêteurs veulent le confronter à
toutes ces contradictions
contre toute attente Claude nolibet
campe sur ses positions
on note beaucoup d'incohérences pour les
clés il ne démord pas ses clés c'est lui
qui les a mises sur
dans la serrure alors qu'on lui montre
les auditions des autres personnes de
plusieurs autres personnes qui montrent
que les clés étaient en position de sa
fille et bien il n'en démord pas il
reste sa version initiale qui dit c'est
moi qui ai mis les clés pour que tout
lui permettre de rentrer plus facilement
[Musique]
les heures passent et Claude nolybe ne
lâche rien
il est formel sur l'heure de son coucher
les gendarmes sont stupéfaits pourquoi
l'homme nie t-il l'évidence
[Musique]
et il n'a pas de réponse oui il est là
il subit il a une attitude assez
particulière il
ne s'effondre pas et il n'est pas dans
gémissement il n'est pas dans la révolte
il subit sa garde à vue un peu comme une
fatalité
et en revanche il ne bouge pas d'un
millimètre dans ces déclarations les
gendarmes décident alors de confronter
Claude nolibet avec les témoins après
son ex-femme c'est au tour de Valérie
une amie de Caroline
[Musique]
la jeune fille affirme être passée
devant la maison le soir du drame et
elle est formelle elle a bien vu un
trousseau de clés sur la porte c'était
un trousseau de clé jaune celui de
Claude nolybe
après cette dernière confrontation
Claude nolybe vacille échange subitement
de version
il va dire aux gens là bon bah écoutez
moi j'étais convaincu jusqu'à présent
que j'avais raison et puis maintenant
j'ai un peu l'impression que je me suis
trompé peut-être que c'était les miennes
peut-être qui avait plus de clé
peut-être que je n'en sais plus rien
quoi
alors là
on en est plus à une contradiction près
chez Monsieur nolivet et on comprend pas
ce revirement qui vient en fin de garde
à vue on ne comprend pas Claude nolybe
est incapable de fournir des
explications claires et précises l'homme
se montre de plus en plus ambigu dans
ses réponses surtout quand on
l'interroge sur la nature exacte de ses
relations avec sa fille
avez-vous eu des relations sexuelles
avec votre fille non jamais Caroline
avait suffisamment de copains pour ne
pas avoir accouché avec moi aviez-vous
des attirances réciproques je n'ai
jamais ressenti d'attirance envers ma
fille pour sa part je n'en sais rien si
ce n'est qu'elle était gentille avec moi
les gendarmes tentent alors de le faire
craquer en vain l'homme ne passe pas aux
aveux
il encaisse un peu comme un mauvais
boxeur qui prend des coups et qui est
sonnait mais qui ne tombe pas il tombe
pas il saigne pas non plus
il est assez atypique finalement Claude
de nolibet son attitude passive durant
tout l'interrogatoire ne fait que
renforcer la conviction des enquêteurs
Claude nolibet a tué sa fille
à l'issue de 48 heures de garde à vue il
est mis en examen pour le meurtre de
Caroline
[Musique]
et je crois qu'ils sont je sais pas s'il
a conscience que ce sont ces
incohérences qui l'ont mené là je crois
qu'il en a pas conscience Claude nolybe
est immédiatement conduit à la maison
d'arrêt d'Agen
sans aveu et sans témoin la juge
d'instruction c'est que le dossier est
très fragile elle demande donc une
nouvelle perquisition dans la maison de
Claude nolybe à la recherche d'une
preuve matérielle
les enquêteurs passent la maison au
peigne fin
on découvre à l'intérieur de la maison
[Musique]
des taches de sang dans l'évier rien ne
prédisposé à ce que cette tâche de sang
se trouve dans cet évier qui était à
l'arrière de la cuisine dans l'arrière
cuisine voilà et également on trouve des
vêtements à Caroline nolibet dans sa
garde-robe qui sont
qui sont cachés on ne sait pas ce que
sont ces tâches donc que fait-on on les
saisit et on les donne à l'expertise
quelques jours plus tard les premiers
rapports arrivent sur le bureau des
enquêteurs
les résultats d'analyse des différents
laboratoires n'apporte rigoureusement
rien les couteaux saisis dans la chambre
de Claude nolybe ne porte aucune trace
de sang
idem pour les vêtements tachés de
Caroline
quant à la trace de sang dans l'évier de
la buanderie il est d'origine animale
pour l'heure aucun élément matériel ne
vient étayer la culpabilité de clones
nolibet mais un nouveau rapport ne va
pas tarder à relancer l'affaire
c'est le rapport de l'expert judiciaire
en trace de sang
[Musique]
il contredit tout à fait les
déclarations de mission de Limay les
affirmations de Monsieur nolibet sur la
position du corps sur la manipulation ne
sont pas ne sont pas celles que l'expert
met en valeur plusieurs points à câbles
clones
le sang retrouvé sur son pantalon et
bien celui de Caroline
mais il affirme que les tâches de sang
retrouvées sur le jean de Claude nolibet
sont des tâches qui viennent de
projection de sang et non pas de
frottement projection ça veut dire qu'il
faut être là au moment du crime quand
l'artère est
transpercé il y a un jet de sang donc ce
serait à ce moment-là
ce qui ne correspond pas du tout à ce
que raconte Claude nolybe le rapport de
l'expert permet de mettre en lumière une
autre incohérence
on ne comprend pas pourquoi alors qu'il
était torse nu
il a du sang partout sauf sur le torse
pour les enquêteurs au moment du meurtre
Claude nolybey portait une chemise dont
il s'est vite débarrassé avant l'arrivée
des gendarmes
et ce n'est pas tout
[Musique]
il y a la fameuse tâche de sang sur le
volet de la cuisine
cette tâche Claude Noly a toujours
expliqué que c'est lui qui l'avait fait
en revenant vers la maison
ses mains sont ensanglantées
c'est lui qui a touché le volet et qui a
marqué le volet de choses qui pour nous
tous ensemble que totalement
impossible les experts montrent qu'il
n'y a pas de traces de mai il y a pas de
d'empreintes ni rien du tout c'est une
transpirationnalité d'un tissu selon
l'expert c'est Caroline blessé qui a
fait cette marque en s'affalant contre
le volet
n'arrive pas à nous enlever de la tête
que il y a quelque chose qui va pas dans
les allées venus dans il y a quelque
chose qui va pas qui est incohérent
pour y voir plus clair la juge
d'instruction organise une
reconstitution
mise en situation sur les lieux du drame
la magistrate espère bien que Claude
nolibet va passer aux aveux
je crois qu'il s'agit de faire craquer
j'étais présent à cette reconstitution
qui a été très très longue qui s'est
prolongé très tard dans la nuit j'ai
l'image de Danone qui arrive entre deux
gendarmes les mains ficelées ou
attachées avec les menottes très très
serrées derrière baissant le baissant la
tête et que l'on pousse un peu comme un
comme quelqu'un qu'on emmène un peu à
l'échafaud
il est très mal à l'aise mais malgré
tout il ne va pas crier son innocence
Claude Olivet c'est soumis à tout ce
qu'on lui a demandé il a été d'une
complaisance totale vis-à-vis de ce que
lui demandait de faire le jus
d'instruction le procureur les
enquêteurs monsieur prête à tous les
gestes sauf quand la magistrate lui
demande de voir quel geste il a fait
avec le corps de sa fille à ce moment-là
la juge d'instruction demande au père de
Caroline de se saisir d'une enquêtrice
badigeonnée de faux sang l'homme craque
pour la première fois
il nous dit une attitude même à limite
agressive
devant ce qu'on lui demande de faire et
c'est là qu'il a qu'il a qu'il a explosé
et qu'il a dit mais je suis pas coupable
il faut vous le dire comment je ne suis
pas coupable là tout le monde a été
pétrifié je dois dire on entendait le
mot jouer
la reconstitution s'achève à deux heures
du matin
dès le lendemain l'avocat de Claude
nolibet dépose une demande de remise en
liberté
des incohérences il y a des
contradictions qui sont pas levées
encore toutes mais il n'y a pas
d'éléments
probant il n'y a pas de preuve formelle
comme quoi que nos Libé et coupable
faute d'éléments matériels et de
témoignages directs la juge
d'instruction décide de remettre Claude
nolibet en liberté le 27 septembre 1991
après 45 jours de détention provisoire
il quitte la maison d'arrêt d'Agen mais
il reste mis en examen pour l'assassinat
de sa fille
il n'est pas disculpé et ça c'est tout
le calvaire qui commence
[Musique]
Claude nolybe retourne à Clairac aux
yeux de tous il est un meurtrier
il a la suspicion qui est tombée sur lui
il se sent épié partout le désigne ça le
désigner les regards sont là ils me
disait quand je vais au cimetière porter
des fleurs sur la tombe de ma fille je
vois bien comme regarde mais on me
regarde de côté on n'adresse pas la
parole il y en avait qui disait regardez
il montre qu'il a de la peine alors que
c'est lui qui l'a tué il va apprendre à
ses dépenses dans les jours dans les
mois dans les années qui suivent qu'il
est devenu un paria
à la section de recherche d'Agen le
meurtre de Caroline a laissé un goût
amer les gendarmes sont persuadés d'être
passé à côté d'un élément crucial
en octobre 1994 le colonel Sasso et muté
l'enquête est reprise par le chef du
chant qui a bien conscience que la terre
est délicate
cette fille-là est poignardée quand on
fait le point quand on fait réellement
son environnement ce que ce qu'avait
fait les enquêteurs précédents il y a
aucun élément qui permet de dire mais ça
peut être X ou Y pour telle ou telle
raison voilà c'est il y a vraiment
aucune hypothèse de travail qui sort par
rapport à une autre parce que on trouve
aucun mobile possible
pas de mobile pas de nouveautés les
enquêteurs doivent repartir de zéro
[Musique]
on reprend la procédure on lit tout
toutes les auditions on revoit les
constatations et puis on essaie de
trouver des trouver des pistes qui n'ont
pas ou des hypothèses qui n'ont pas été
fermées ou des choses qui n'ont pas été
vu parmi les pistes vit abandonnés il y
en a une qui retient l'attention du
gendarme
[Musique]
c'est le foyer de travailleurs
handicapés mentaux à côté de chez
Caroline
ce foyer situé sur le trajet de la
victime quand elle rentrait chez elle et
si nous avons pris cette piste là c'est
tout simplement parce qu'on a dû estimer
que les enquêteurs à l'origine c'est à
dire en 91 n'avait pas creusé
suffisamment
initialement
le directeur de l'époque avait indiqué
aux enquêteurs que son centre était vide
de tout occupant le soir des faits parce
que c'était les vacances mais une
information intéressante parvient aux
oreilles des enquêteurs
des pensionnaires auraient passé la nuit
du meurtre au foyer
les gendarmes contactent de nouveau le
directeur pour en avoir le cœur net
on a ni plus moyen de demander la liste
des personnes présentes des jeunes
présents au foyer
le soir du meurtre cette liste nous a
été communiquée
plusieurs mois plus tard et là surprise
plusieurs pensionnaires ont bien dormi
au centre cette nuit là
cette liste se comportait cinq noms elle
l'un d'entre eux serait-il le meurtrier
de Caroline les gendarmes vérifient les
antécédents des 5 nouveaux suspects
nous avons interrogé notre fichier
central pour savoir si ces personnes
étaient déjà connues sur le plan
judiciaire
et la réponse a été négative rien dans
la vie et dans le parcours de ces cinq
hommes ne retient l'attention des
gendarmes
la piste du foyer pour handicaper est
écarté
le mystère du meurtre de Caroline reste
entier
il est arrivé à un moment où oui
effectivement on avait fait le tour on
avait fait le tour et on a dit une ben
nous aussi là on trouvera pas
honnêtement là moi j'ai plus de sport
le 6 août 1997 après 6 ans d'enquête
instructueuse Claude nolybet bénéficie
d'un non-lieu
mais à Clairac ce n'est pas du goût de
tout le monde
ça change rien du tout pour pour Claude
ce change rien du tout c'est toujours le
paria c'est toujours la saceène c'est
toujours le gars qui a tué sa fille pas
de réponse c'est le poids toujours plus
lourd de la suspicion le père de
Caroline s'enfonce dans la dépression
sa vie privée était massacrée parce que
il avait cherché à reconstituer un
couple mais ça a été un échec puis notre
échec puis encore un autre échec il a
changé plusieurs fois de domicile il a
tenté de reprendre son travail mais très
très vite il en a pas été capable il en
avait plus la force il a été déclaré
invalide elle s'occupe comme il peut il
tue le temps
[Musique]
et surtout surtout il est bourré
d'antidépresseurs
et il ne vit pas il survit
[Musique]
les mois puis les années passent
l'enquête est au point mort pourtant un
incroyable coup du sort va permettre de
relancer le dossier
[Musique]
le 10 mai 2001 une femme de ménage de
l'Institut de Castille à Clairac est en
train de passer l'aspirateur dans la
chambre d'un pensionnaire
et son aspirateur est bloqué par une
boulette de papier et sur cette boulette
de papier qu'elle prend de sa main et
qu'elle déplie elle découvre mot qui est
écrit d'une main assez malhabile et qui
indique que c'est moi qui ai tué la
fille Nolibé à Clairac
un véritable coup de tonnerre l'auteur
du mot précise la date des faits la nuit
du 31 juillet au 1er août 91 il
mentionne aussi le lieu d'humeurtre
Longueville le hameau où vivait Caroline
à côté de Clairac
la femme de ménage réalise que ce mot
est à prendre très au sérieux cet aveu
rédigé sur un bout de papier a été
trouvé dans la chambre d'un certain
Philippe gain 12 36 ans
immédiatement elle se précipite dans le
bureau du directeur pour lui transmettre
ce document qu'elle a qu'elle a trouvé
par inadvertance on a l'alerte la
gendarmerie les enquêteurs apprennent
que 10 ans après les faits un
pensionnaire du foyer s'accuse du
meurtre
je crois que tout était écroulé sous moi
je n'arrivais pas à comprendre comment
on n'est plus en arriver là
mais il y a un problème
Philippe gain 12 est déficient mental
ces aveux ses aveux écrits sont-ils
crédibles
les gendarmes cherchent à en savoir plus
sur sa personnalité
à l'Institut personne ne croit sa
culpabilité
Dominique crie de l'Auze était
infirmière au centre elle connaissait
Philippe guendouze depuis plus de 10 ans
alors là je suis tombé des nues parce
que bon Philippe il avait une attitude
presque normale Philippe bien 12 c'est
un enfant dans le corps d'un homme de 40
ans et donc quand vous le voyez c'est
vrai que c'est quelqu'un qui paraît
plutôt il faut le dire qui paraît plutôt
inoffensif Philippe gain 12 est chargé
de ranger les articles de papeterie du
centre Castille d'après les éducateurs
il est bien intégré poli et respectueux
il avait une petite copine avec qui ça
allait très très bien c'était un gamin
bon moi ma fille ma fille je vous tennis
de table avec lui il y a jamais eu une
histoire il y a jamais eu un geste
déplacer j'ai du mal à l'imaginer dans
la faire ça l'homme semble au-dessus de
tout soupçon pourtant en fouillant son
passé les gendarmes vont faire une
découverte capitale
[Musique]
Philippe gain 12 n'a pas de casier mais
il a des antécédents judiciaires
le passé est de ganouze là il nous donne
une explication de ce qui a pu se faire
il a déjà en Lot-et-Garonne et à
proximité de Clairac agresser une jeune
fille avec un couteau
les gendarmes découvrent le dossier
c'était le 12 novembre 1985 ce jour-là
Philippe Guen 12 avait suivi une jeune
fille dans la rue sans raison il l'avait
ensuite poignardé avant de s'enfuir en
la laissant très grièvement blessé
[Musique]
on a un mode opératoire entre les deux
agressions qui est quasiment identique
Philippe gain 12 a été immédiatement
arrêté mais en raison de son handicap
l'homme a été déclaré pénalement
irresponsable et n'a pas été jugé
il a été hospitalisé d'office parce
qu'il a été donc détourné vers la
psychiatrie et après quand son état n'a
plus été considérée comme dangereux il
est ressortir revenu dans le milieu où
il se trouvait
à Clairac l'enquête redémarre ce
Philippe gain 12 fait un suspect idéal
[Musique]
mais rapidement les gendarmes des
chantent ils n'étaient pas au foyer la
nuit du drame
le nom de Philippe guendoz ne figure pas
sur la liste
des individus pensionnaires
présents le soir du 31 juillet les
enquêteurs ne renoncent pas la liste
fournie en 1995 n'est peut-être pas
complète ils vont faire de nouvelles
recherches dans les archives du centre
[Musique]
et donc ils vont demander une deuxième
liste avec insistance
cette liste va finir par sortir et là
aux surprises Philippe gain 12 apparaît
dans la liste
en plus des seins que qui avait déjà été
cités dans la liste communiquée par
l'ancien directeur le nom de Philippe
guendouze n'apparaissait pas négligence
oublie volontaire les gendarmes n'en
savent rien mais désormais Philippe
gainedouze n'a plus d'alibi il devient
suspect numéro un dans la mort de
Caroline nolybe il est temps pour eux de
l'interpeller nous sommes le 30 mai 2001
[Musique]
ils investissent les lieux ils arrivent
dans la petite chambre de Philippe
guendouze il l'interpelle il l'arrête il
me note
et il commence à lui expliquer les
raisons de leur présence il lui explique
qu'il est en garde à vue les enquêteurs
très rapidement vont effectuer une
perquisition dans la chambre de
Philippiens 12 et là ils vont trouver un
Opinel un couteau Opinel peu de chance
que ce soit l'arme du crime si longtemps
plus tard
mais ils vont trouver une enveloppe une
enveloppe sur laquelle
il est écrit les personnes que j'ai à
tuer
et il figure trois noms deux éducatrices
et une stagiaire
Philippe guendouze est emmenée dans les
locaux de la gendarmerie l'homme est
détendu souriant et ne tarde pas à
reconnaître qu'il est bien l'auteur du
mot
c'est bien moi qui l'ai écrit
j'ai marqué la vérité sur ce papier je
ne sais pas pourquoi j'ai eu besoin
d'écrire ça
il avoue dans la foulée à avoir tué
Caroline
c'est bien moi qui ai tué la fille nolib
c'était à la fin du mois de juillet la
veille que je parte en vacances il
explique
que cette jeune fille
passée devant sa fenêtre quasiment tous
les jours quelques fois plusieurs fois
par jour
quel était toujours très jolie toujours
très apprêtée que ce soir-là avant de
partir en vacances il avait décidé de la
suivre et là il prend son couteau son
Opinel il part derrière elle comme la
fille a pris de l'avance je cours pour
me rapprocher d'elle
il la rattrape
au départ je voulais juste lui faire
peur et puis je ne sais pas pourquoi je
l'ai frappé vers le haut du corps elle
n'est pas tombée et elle a le temps de
lui dire et c'est lui qui le révèle mais
qu'est-ce que je t'ai fait
je la poignarde une autre fois vers le
ventre sans voir où je la touche
mais qu'est-ce que je t'ai fait Caroline
vient d'être frappé en plein cœur
et on va enfin voir comprendre la
terrible fin les derniers instants de de
Caroline
elle est agressée à 70 mètres de chez
elle
ensuite il va rentrer chez lui nettoyer
son couteau et puis se coucher
il est extrêmement précis donne un
certain nombre de détails il ne cache
rien
l'homme raconte volontiers ce qu'il a
fait
mais une question demeure pourquoi quel
est le mobile du meurtre de Caroline
c'est l'expertise psychiatrique qui va
permettre d'en savoir plus
c'est quelqu'un qui parle spontanément
donc de l'acte qu'il a avoué avoir
commis à savoir donc j'ai tué une fille
ce qu'il dit c'est que il a suivi parce
que il la connaissait de vue et donc il
avait remarqué alors est-il capable de
dire s'il avait un désir sexuel ou
amoureux c'est difficile d'obtenir ce
propos de lui ce qu'il dit c'est que il
avoue quand même qu'il avait quelque
chose en vers cette vie peut-être du
désir pour le père de Caroline les aveux
de Philippe gain 12 sont une délivrance
te soulagement il a enfin l'assassin de
sa fille c'était la fin de son cauchemar
quoi on trouvait le vrai coupable ce
qu'il avait espéré et qui n'espérait
plus
le 31 mai 2001 Philippe guendouze est
mise en examen pour assassinat et placer
en détention provisoire
mais le 28 septembre coûtaitâtre dans le
bureau du magistrat instructeur il
revient intégralement sur ses aveux
êtes-vous oui ou non l'assassin de
Caroline nolibet non
avez-vous inventé les gestes que vous
avez fait oui
curieux revirement alors que Philippe
gain 12 a su fournir quantité de détails
sur la soirée du crime quelques semaines
plus tôt
une question se pose pour la juge
d'instruction
est-il pénalement responsable sa place
n'est-elle pas plutôt en hôpital
psychiatrique une nouvelle expertise est
ordonnée c'est le docteur Fabien Aubat
qui examine Philippe gain 12 il comprend
la gravité de évidemment des faits en
eux-mêmes je lui avais dit et bien
d'après vous pour celui qui aurait commé
ce type de fait quel est le quantum de
la peine qui pourrait être retenu mais
il dit 30 ans mais si c'était vous qui
étiez condamné mais à 15 ou 20 ans alors
c'est amusant parce que quand je lui dis
si c'était vous qui était condamné il se
a failli manifeste pas une grande
indignation vis-à-vis de ça ou de
surprises ou de refus
selon l'expert psychiatrique Philippe
gain 12 est donc pénalement responsable
il peut être jugé
[Musique]
pour les enquêteurs et la juge plusieurs
interrogations demeurent pourquoi la
piste du CAT n'a-t-elle pas abouti plus
tôt pourquoi l'ancien directeur a-t-il
dit que Philippe gain 12 était absent le
soir du meurtre
entendu sur ce point Philippe gain 12
fait une révélation fracassante
l'ancien directeur était au courant
[Musique]
le directeur se dit si je donne ce nom
je vais avoir des tas d'ennuis
parce que bien entendu
on va faire le rapprochement avec
l'effet précédent et qui sait on va me
reprocher un défaut de surveillance de
mes pensionnaires et par l'acheter ce
personnage donnera pas le nom avec le
nolibet nous déposons une plainte une
plainte pour Russell de malfaiteur
malheureusement la cour d'appel a
considéré
que c'est fait était prescrit les
poursuites sont abandonnées l'ancien
directeur de l'établissement n'a pas à
répondre de ses actes
le 12 janvier 2004 le procès de Philippe
guendouze s'ouvre devant la cour
d'assises d'Agen un moment que Claude
nolibet attend depuis 13 ans
il atteint de se procès une
réhabilitation enfin que enfin on ne
pense plus un Olibet est un assassin
Philippe gain 12 fait son entrée dans le
box des accusés
c'est pas quelqu'un qui fait peur c'est
pas quelqu'un qui fait peur c'est pas
quelqu'un qu'on imagine avec un couteau
en train de vous poursuivre pour vous
assassiner etc
au contraire Philippe vient 12 je dirais
qu'il a presque plutôt l'air sympathique
il a presque plutôt l'air sympathique et
en tout cas il inspire plus plus
peut-être la pitié que la haine pas une
fois Philippe gain 12 ne semble
s'inquiéter de l'issue de ce procès
l'homme paraît presque absent des débats
tout au long de l'audience on s'aperçoit
qu'il a pas la lumière à tous les étages
il a pas l'air de de
jauger la gravité de la chose pour
laquelle il est là Claude nolibet lui
veut enfin comprendre pourquoi Caroline
a-t-elle été tuée
il n'y a pas de véritable explication
c'est un crime gratuit ça crime pour
rien il y avait pas de mobile c'est
parce qu'elle est passée là
il y a pas d'autres explications le
procès n'apporte aucune réponse au père
de Caroline
mais à la fin des débats une chose
rarissime se produit le procureur se
lève et s'adresse directement à Claude
Noly
une nuit présente au nom de toute la
justice des excuses solennelles parce
qu'à l'évidence la justice c'est trompé
je n'ai pas vu en 40 ans de métier un
magistrat
capable de formuler de cette façon des
excuses à propos d'une erreur à l'issue
du procès Philippe gain 12 est condamné
à 15 ans de réclusion criminelle pour le
meurtre de Caroline nolibet à l'énoncé
du verdict il reste impassible
il réalise je crois qu'il réalise parce
qu'il y arrive il comprend pas tout quoi
là
pour le père de Caroline le verdict est
une libération son cauchemar aura duré
13 ans je me rappelle de m'avoir vu
quelqu'un qui avait un sourire en bien
de soulager d'un poids pour Claude
nolibet ce qui était important c'est que
la culpabilité soit reconnue Claude
nolibet vit toujours dans la région de
Clairac aujourd'hui il n'arrive toujours
pas à surmonter son chagrin
cette affaire est devenue une sorte de
prison dans laquelle il est toujours
enfermé aujourd'hui
[Musique]